welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page reproduction
the new york times so in this video
we are going to reproduce the new york
times front page
from scratch using grid grid-based
layout so one of our main purposes in
this video
is to show you that using grid-based
layout you can actually create some very
complex websites
without that much trouble there are some
nuances we're going to see
in reproducing this web page but for the
most part it's actually pretty
straightforward
i certainly would not try to do this
with either float based layout or
flexbox layout
so this move to grid-based layout has
really opened up a lot of doors for
people
in terms of being able to create
relatively complex websites without that
much difficulty
so let's get started so this is the uh
copy of the new york times we're going
to be working with there are a couple
different things to notice about this
website
first of all you'll notice that there
are three main columns
um as shown here and that
um there are a few areas which don't
really follow the column rule so
we look at this section down near the
bottom you can see that that actually
crosses two columns so that's basically
column span
and then if we look at the photo up at
the top that also
goes across multiple columns and then
there's that
center row that
just kind of violates the rules of the
other section
i'm going to ignore that for now and
then we'll get back to it and fix it
before this video is over but for now
we're just going to assume that section
is not there and that
everything either follows these main
three rows
or is a calm span on these main three
rows
now what you've got here is on our left
this is the
copy of the new york times that we are
going to create from scratch
and on the right this is a screenshot of
the actual new york times so
you know it's pretty close i am missing
some things i don't have the
light gray comments saying how long ago
a particular article was created or how
many comments there were on there
and you'll notice that i am using the
lorem ipsum
again which uh just as a reminder lorem
ipsum
is randomized latin text from cicero
it's
quite commonly used in
as example text and type setting
situation so we're going to go ahead and
follow that
our alarm ipsum i think is a little bit
more uplifting than
the then the headlines from
the days when i took this uh photograph
and recreated this last
uh last year and certainly
more uplifting than what's going on
right now and then of course i'm
replacing the photographs
i like my photographs better too all
right
let's start off by taking a quick look
at the original html
um so this is the html
in the body and you can see i've got a
number of sections here i've
basically created a number of divs and
i'm going to label them
a1 for the divs associated with the
first row
so there's a1 and a2 for the first row
b1 b2 and b3 for the second row and then
c1 and c2 for the third row
but i do want to emphasize that because
this
is a grid-based layout
i am not limited by the order in which
these appear
in the html i put them in the html
and given them labels uh which are
appropriate for
the layout we're planning to do but in
fact we could rearrange these in any
order we want
with no problems and this is one of the
huge benefits of grid based layout
if we were doing float based layout or
flexbox layout we absolutely could not
do this so
you know lots of flexibility and the
other bit of flexibility which we're not
going to be talking about today but
definitely is very important is that not
only can we move these around
anywhere on this current layout but we
can create an entirely different grid
for different devices so
one grid for large desktop monitors
another grid for tablets and then a
third grid for cell phones
and i can move any of the elements to
any of the locations on any of those
grids so
big win for grid-based layout plus as i
mentioned earlier it really is
way easier you know as i said i would
definitely not be
trying to reproduce this page with float
based layout or flexbox layout
okay so uh for now we're going to go
ahead and put our grid in the body
we'll go back to the on this decision a
little bit later and talk about you know
alternatives but for now i'm just going
to go ahead and put in the body
i need to tell the web browser that the
body of the web page is a grid
and that there are three columns of 400
pixels 360 pixels and 240 pixels
and i basically i picked those by going
into uh photoshop and doing some
measurements on the original new york
times so
uh so we could get an accurate
comparison to what they were using
as far as the rows go you'll notice that
there
are these lines running between each of
the sections
now there are a couple different ways to
create these lines
one possibility is to put top borders on
each of the elements
but that turns out to cause a bit of a
problem
and um so what i'm showing you on the
inside here
is uh what one of those lines would have
looked like
if i were using them on each of the
elements and if you look closely you'll
notice that there are breaks in that
line
and so those breaks are coming from the
margins
or alternatively we haven't talked about
this but there's a there's a
particular way to create the cloven of
margins
in grid-based layout called gaps so
whether you're using margins or using
gaps you are going to get breaks in that
top
top border and so the top border does
not work very well that way
so what i've done instead is i'm going
to go ahead and create
divs for each of these um i'm going to
give them different classes because the
top line in the new york times is
actually
thicker than the other ones and so i'm
going to go ahead and create
different divs for each of these i'm
going to go ahead and give them classes
now as to where i want to put divs
within the
html file they do need to be children of
the body because the body is where the
grid's located but other than that
i can put them directly above the divs
representing the different
uh articles and images i can put them on
the bottom
uh i can put interspace them between
each of the different rows
it doesn't really matter i can go ahead
and take any div that is a child of the
body
and place it within the grid set up for
the body so
the exact placement of these divs is
really a matter of personal choice
i went ahead and um if you take a look
at the source code i'm going to go ahead
and release my source to you guys
you'll see that i actually interspersed
it so that
the div for that double wide line up at
the top is before the divs for the a
section
uh and then i've got a div between the a
section of the b
section and then i've got a dip between
b section in the c section and then i've
got a div down at the bottom but
you really can place them wherever you
want
okay and so here are the rules that i'm
using to actually create the lines
you can see i am creating a border
on the top of these divs that don't
actually have any contents
i am setting a margin on
the top and bottom of 5 pixels in
a margin of zero on the right and the
left and so remember
if you list two different values for the
margin
or the padding um the
one the first one listed is associated
with the top and the bottom and
the second one listed is associated with
the right and the left
also you should put measurement types
for
each of your measurements for example
5px representing pixels
unless the value is 0. if you're using
zero it doesn't matter whether it's zero
inches zero millimeter
zero pixels zero is just zero
you may also be wondering you know i
talked about how
you couldn't use a border a minute ago
because you're gonna have breaks in the
border
why am i using a border now isn't this
what i just told you a couple minutes
ago wouldn't work
well the difference here is that these
divs go all the way across the web page
the issue with the breaks is that if
you have a number of different columns
and
your elements are breaking along those
columns
and you need to put margins them that's
where the breaks are going to occur
these particular divs go across all of
the columns and so let's actually take a
look at that next and here's where i'm
actually placing
the uh these divs and so you can see i
am placing one in row one
and then row two is the actual contents
uh including the photo of venice
and then i am placing one in row
three and then row four uh that's the
row with uh
london bridge in there and then i'm
placing one of these at row five
and then row six that's the last section
of text and then i'm placing one at row
seven so
every other row is going to have one of
these divs
and then how how are these divs being
placed these divs start in column one
they go across columns two and three and
then
remember the n rows actually beyond uh
the end of where we actually want these
to go so there's a non-existent row four
and that is the end point for these
elements and there again
you know i i'm emphasizing that these
run across
elements one two and three and
the problem if we had put the borders
on the individual elements is there
could have been a break between
row one and row two or row two and row
three and because these go across all
those rows i don't need to worry about
those gaps
appearing okay as far as
the rows go um i've set the columns at
400 pixels 360 pixels and 240 pixels and
as far as the rows go
i'm going to leave that at auto so this
means that the
rows will increase or decrease in height
depending upon the actual contents
placed within the row
all right so let's go ahead and place
the items into the web page
uh this is pretty straightforward for
the most part but we will see there
there are a few issues that come up
okay so i'm going to go ahead and place
my a1 section that's the
actual original lorem ipsum that goes in
the top left
notice that uh this has an h2 in it and
it's got
a honor list with a bunch of list items
and the point here is you know this is a
div you can put
any renderable elements inside of a div
you can put photographs you can put
tables you can put paragraphs you can
put headings
anything can go inside of a div so
basically any one of these squares
within the grid
that we've defined for the main body any
of these grid elements can contain
any html we want in them
okay so i'm going to go ahead and put
this in row 2 because remember row 1
is that double thick line up at the top
so i'm going to go ahead and put this in
row 2 in column 1.
i don't need to list an end column
because
this is only filling up a single square
on the grid and then i am going to go
ahead and set a margin here so
you will see margins appearing at
various points um
in my grid placement and that's just to
try and get a little bit of extra space
i'll have to admit i did not pay that
much attention to making it match
exactly the amount of space that the new
york times was using
but i did want a little bit of space
there if i didn't put that margin right
eight picks
that image of venice would be bumping
right up against the uh
text there and that would look a little
bit odd
okay and so here's the image itself um
you can see i am putting this in
row two same as uh the alarm ipsum on
its left
um it is going from column two to column
four so that means it's crossing columns
two and three again
ending the end is one pass where we're
actually covering
so that's column four um so this is a
column spanning image
uh and you can see that i've given a
specific
width of 600 pixels now this part is
actually important
the width of the image will vary
depending upon where we want to place it
obviously if i want to put it in a
single column instead of uh
multiple columns with the column span
like we have here that's going to make
it much shorter
but you know even if we were to move it
if we were to move it from
its position up in the top right to the
left side
i would actually need to increase the
width so
covering columns two and three is 600
pixels coloring
covering columns one or two is actually
760 pixels and you can work that out
by just looking at the uh the width of
the column so
we can see that the left column is 400
pixels which means the right two columns
is 600 pixels
uh if we move it over to the left two
columns that is the 400 pixels plus the
360 pixels so that gives us 760 pixels
so depending on how you want to
place the images you do need to increase
or decrease the width
all right so now we're going down to the
next row
remember row 3 is actually that border
between uh the a section and the b
section so now we're in the b
section the b section is being placed in
row four
um and again you can see i i am putting
a little bit of a margin there
now this next one's a little bit more
interesting this includes
both the image as well as the caption
underneath the image
um and again i mentioned this just a
minute ago but
you know b2 is just a div and inside of
div you can put whatever you want
so it's certainly fine for me to put
both an image and a paragraph into it
uh again as with the image of venice we
do need to set a width on this
or alternatively i suppose you could set
a height i think the width makes a lot
more sense here though
it's easy to calculate we know how wide
the columns are we don't know how tall
the uh
the rows are going to be um so i'm going
to go ahead and set a width on this
and then i am going to also
uh let's change the color of the caption
down at the bottom and i
do want to shrink the text up a bit uh
to match more or less what the new york
times was doing
uh for their for their caption on their
image down there
all right and then on the far right um
i'm going to go ahead
and put my last element for the b
section now if we look closely at the
original from new york times you can see
that there is that
light gray line running vertically
between the image on the left and the
news article on the right and so i went
ahead and tried to reproduce that
mine it looks like i really should have
increased the margin between that image
and the border it's a little bit hard
seeing the border but
again you know there's a one pixel saw
light gray border you can kind of see it
there
it's much more prominent on the new york
times which means i i messed up a little
bit on my design there
uh but yeah so go ahead and put a little
bit of
margin and padding and then put the
light gray border to
to reproduce what they're doing there
and then finally i have the c-section
here
the c-section is a little bit
interesting because if you look at the
original
you can see here johnson and johnson
recalls and if you look at the amount of
space there between johnson and johnson
and the text on the right side you know
that word recalls
could totally fit in that space if they
want it
similarly taint it uh probably
could have fit between asbestos and the
next column over so they
actually pushed that
title and they made it shorter than the
actual amount of space on the column
and so that's what i've gone ahead and
done here i've set the
width of this particular element to only
250 pixels
so the column takes up more space than
the text here and i'm forcing the text
to have a bit
shorter width uh to try and get it to
match what was going on in the new york
times there
and then find the last element and so
the
main thing that's interesting about this
last element is it is doing a column
span so it starts in
column two and then it crosses columns
two and three
and then so we list the end as one past
the column three so i
list the end as column four all right so
we've been looking at
close in screenshots of just the
contents of the web page let's back out
a minute here and take a look at
what this looks like in a web browser so
based on what we've got right now
this image here on the left this is what
this web page looks like in a web
browser
now probably what we want is
more like what we have here on the right
this is the way the new york times
actually works and so the difference
here is
with the image on the left you can see
that
when the web browser window gets wider
my web page sits
stuck to the top left-hand corner of the
web page and i can increase the width of
the window
and i'm going to get wider and wider
right margins but the left margin
is still fixed at zero and so on the
right side we can see that the
uh the web page stays in the middle of
the browser window and as we increase
the width of the browser window
space will increase on both the left and
the right side and so we've seen this
effect before and
as you'll recall the way to fix this is
to put the entire contents of the web
page
into a div and i've been given that div
the id
main and so here you can see i've i've
gone ahead and everything that
previously was in the body is now inside
of this
div with id equals main now
as for how i actually worked out the
margins i i will have to admit it
probably
a little overkill in terms of going all
in on the grid-based layout
i laid it out with a grid um it does
give you another chance to
to see how grid works but i i could have
just put left and right margins on id
main that probably would have been a
better move but
let's go ahead and take a look at how i
did this here okay so i said that the
body is also grid
and that the grid in the body has three
columns
one column is set to 1fr the middle
column is set to 1000 pixels and the
last column is set to 1fr
and so you recall from our previous
discussion on what fr means fr is
short for fractional and so
fractional the frs are going to take up
the extra space
not used by the fixed element so we have
a thousand pixel fixed element
and then any additional space in the web
browser window
for the in this case for the width since
we're doing with columns
that's going to be divided between our
two frs
and so that's going to split the
extra space between the left margin and
the right margin
or in this case the left column and the
right column
which are empty and then as far as
main goes uh now i need to go ahead and
place that
in the grid that that the body has so
the body has a grid
and so this is going to appear in row 1
and then it's going to be in column 2
because column 1
is that blank 1 fr on the left and then
column 3 is that blank fr on the right
and so i want to go ahead and put the
actual main contents of the web page
into column two and then
because i want to place the divs inside
of the
main div onto the web page now
that's going to go into grid in the main
element and so i do need to define that
grid and so
this grid here on id main this is the
grid that used to be on
the uh the body
all right let's go back to that section
that i said i was
ignoring uh and so this is the section
that does not follow the rules
of the other parts of the grid
all right so what are we gonna do with
this well here's a close-up of it
and you can see that there's a number of
different elements on here
in addition to just the fact that it
doesn't follow the
columns of the rest of the web page so
if you look
at the top here you can see that there's
a border running across the top
but it doesn't run all the way across
all three columns
as it does in all the previous cases it
only runs across
two of the columns you'll also notice
that
that last element on the far right that
is actually
captioned for the image up on top of it
and so there's no border there
and it does use that light gray that
they've been using for captions
um and then you'll also notice that
there is a
another line running between the two
stories on the left
so these are all different things that
we want to make sure our solution takes
care of
and so up on the top that's the original
from the new york times and
down in the bottom this is our
reproduction so let's
take a look at how we might reproduce
this so one thing we might do is we
could add an extra column
so here i've got four columns instead of
three columns
the main issue here is just uh
we're gonna have to set calm span on
pretty much all of our elements because
uh other than this one individual row
um everybody else does not follow these
rules and so
they're going to have to have column
span in order to get rid of this this
extra row here
on the other hand uh if we are going to
use this particular set of divisions and
other locations on our web page
this is probably the right way to go so
you know if mostly
we're using the original three columns
but there's a couple places where we
have this alternative
um use of columns and it shows up again
and again in different locations on our
web page then sure
go ahead and add in that fourth column
and then
you know use a column span for all the
elements that
previously would have just taken up
column two uh
those elements are now going to cross
columns two and three
and so you know it's definitely doable
the alternative approach and this is the
one i actually used
was i'm gonna go ahead and have a single
element
span both the original two columns and
then
it's going to have its own internal
structure
and so that's the way i chose to do it
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
source here
you can see that here's
i've got a div i've given the id x1
and that is going to cross both those
columns
from the original setup and it's going
to contain
two internal divs one div i've given the
id
xy1 and the other div i've given the id
xy2 and again these are both inside of
the div
idx1 and then
i've also got id x2 and that's the
caption on the far right
notice that that is not inside of the uh
the div
x1 it is separate from it and it's not
part of that that other structure
okay so let's go ahead and place the x1
structure
here it is right here um key things to
notice here
uh again this contains x y one and x y
two which are the two stories inside of
it
uh notice that this does cross two
columns so
starts in uh well this is obviously row
three
uh starts in column one goes across
column two
ends in column three um
it's got its own border remember we have
that border that goes across just these
two
columns but does not go across the third
column so i went ahead and put a border
on this
and i put in a top margin and a little
bit of padding there
and then finally because this element
has its own internal items and has its
own internal structure i need to go
ahead and define it and
in this case uh since we're we're all
about grid
uh i went ahead and defined a grid
inside here there's there's obviously
other ways to do this
uh and in fact this is you know this
would be a reasonable place to use your
flexbox
um okay so i went ahead and defined a
grid
inside of this element and i said that
there's two columns 460 pixels and 300
pixels
and i'm going to set the row size to
auto and i just need to go ahead and
place those individual elements so
the one on the left that's x y one go
ahead and place that
row one column one and then x y two
uh row one column two
and then the main thing i've added here
is i do have that little light gray
uh border going between these two
elements
again i i was not paying as close
attention to new york times as i should
have i think i think i need to have a
little bit
of a little bit more padding there does
not look
quite uh quite like the original but
you can tell you know same basic idea
would be pretty easy to do a fix on this
and then finally x2 this is not inside
of that div so this is part of the
original structure
and so you know this is
a child of the main div and
it is using the original grid placement
that we're using for all the other
elements on the web page
um i did use the class caption
uh we used this previously uh for the
caption below
london bridge image and we're getting
that kind of light gray
look that that the new york times is
using for that
all right so uh here's the original
uh new york times on the right uh
and then on the left we've got the
reproduction new york times and
hopefully you'll agree with me that this
is you know that's
not exactly match uh could have done a
little bit better job on some of those
margins
um particularly for those those gray
vertical bars as opposed to horizontal
bars but
i mean basically it's the same idea and
you could easily go in and tweak it if
you wanted to so
you know i think
i think using this grid based layout is
makes it
pretty easy to do some pretty complex
stuff and
hopefully you know watching this video
it has been fairly long but hopefully
all of it has been pretty understandable
and you can say hey
you know using what i've i've learned in
this class i do see how i can
recreate a complex web page like the new
york times here
now i actually have another one of these
i have a reproduction of the washington
post
but um having recorded uh this whole new
york times section
uh and thinking about you guys listening
to this this
relatively long reproduction in new york
times i think we should save that for
another day
so we will take a look at uh reproducing
a section of the washington post i think
there's some other interesting lessons
on
on that recreation but uh this will be
it for
uh the recreations for today i'll talk
to you soon
you